pasada la medianoche Israel lanzó un
ataque con misiles sobre la capital
Siria en Damasco que en palabras del
observatorio sirio de Derechos Humanos
supone el ataque israelí más mortífero
hasta la fecha mientras la agencia Siria
sanah informó de cinco fallecidos esta
ong que tiene su sede en Reino Unido
registró al menos 15 muertos por cohetes
que cayeron en la localidad de daguar
almarra pero sobre todo en el barrio
capitalino de cafar suse una zona
Residencial donde se ubica en un centro
cultural iraní y sedes de agencias de
seguridad según el observatorio Israel
habría apuntado a instalaciones de
milicias iraníes y del gesbolá libanés
pero las autoridades sirias detallaron
que el impacto destruyó varias viviendas
de civiles y causó daños materiales en
Damasco y alrededores como es el caso de
una escuela iraní desde 2011 y desde los
altos del Corán ocupado Israel ha
lanzado ataques aéreos contra objetivos
militares iraníes en Siria siendo
comunes los bombardeos contra
aeropuertos y bases aéreas de hecho este
es el segundo ataque Israel en 2023 y el
primero desde el mortífero terremoto que
para Siria ha significado una calamidad
con más de 10 millones de afectados que
se suma a doce años de destrucción por
la guerra civil Aunque Israel no suele
comentar estos ataques el Primer
Ministro Benjamín netaku si se refirió
hoy a Irán y responsabilizó por un
supuesto ataque contra un barco
petrolero en el mar arábigo ocurrido el
10 de febrero y que ocasionó daños leves
en tanto que el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores iraní expresó su condena por
este bombardeo israelí en Damasco y lo
vinculó a un reciente atentado atribuido
al grupo estado islámico que el viernes
dejó al menos 53 civiles muertos en la
provincia de ohms